there are many things that differentiate
human beings from other species but the
one thing that probably differentiates
humans even from our closest relatives
in the animal kingdom in a really big
way is the notion that humans are
collective learners collective learners
and to understand that let's think about
how even our closest relative in the
animal kingdom the chimpanzee might
communicate so you might have one
chimpanzee and over the course of his or
her lifetime they're able to learn a
bunch of cool experiences and they're
even able to learn to use tools
manipulate tools and who knows maybe
even make tools maybe even get a twig
someplace and take off the leaves and
then use that to go get ants out of a
hole or whatever else so they're able to
learn all of this stuff over a lifetime
now unfortunate for chimpanzees well
what is fortune for chimpanzees is they
do teach some of these things that
they've learned to other members of
their group often their offspring but
what's unfortunate for chimpanzees is
they don't have a great way to
communicate with each other so for most
chimpanzees the way that they're able to
teach is essentially by kind of
showing not showing and telling just
showing and so because this is such a
this is such a a unprecise or or not
exact and such an inefficient way of
communication they're really all the
nuances of what this chimpanzee might be
able to accumulate over his or her
lifetime
aren't able to be conveyed to the next
generation or to the other chimpanzees
around so you have tremendous energy
loss and in particular all that can be
conveyed are maybe the specific
movements or what you or what you might
be able to kind of observe in the
present all of the other things that
maybe the chimpanzee is learning about
the times of year where this is
appropriate and maybe they can convey
some of that by showing them at the
right times of year but other nuanced
aspects of it or particular ways to hold
something or twist something can only be
shown it can't be described in a very
precise way so you have all of this loss
of experience this loss of information
and then over the course of these
animals life there may be able to learn
the same amount again they're able to
learn maybe the same amount again but
then when they need to communicate it
they have the exact same problem they
have it's hard to communicate it with
their with what they have at their
disposal which is really just showing
the other chimpanzees what they've done
and so once again you have a loss of
information and what you have in this
type of circumstance is generation after
generation even though there is learning
over the course of an individual
chimpanzee's life
and even though they can communicate to
some of that to each other that form of
communication is so it loses so much
information and so much nuance that you
never have an overall accumulation of of
of knowledge and wisdom in this
chimpanzee population now humans on the
other hand have something called
symbolic language and i'll talk about
this in a second but it's it's for now
it's safe to say that human language is
far more precise and far more efficient
than just being able to show someone
something imagine if if you had to learn
how to do something without being able
to communicate verbally if you just had
to look at someone else's actions and
then you'd have a good idea of how
difficult it is for chimpanzees to teach
each other but in the case of human
beings we have this thing called
symbolic language that's a very precise
a very efficient way of communicating so
from one human being to another you can
actually communicate a good deal maybe
not every single nuance and every single
experience but a good chunk of it so
right here i'm drawing about that much
of it to the next to some other human
being maybe it is the offspring maybe it
is another member of the tribe or the
group or whatever it is and then this
human being might come up with some
other innovations they they're able to
build off of all of this learning from
that previous generation or from that
other human being that's around and
they're able to come up with their own
their own nuances and their own
innovations and this one right over here
might come up with his or her own
nuances and innovations
and because they have a good
communication mechanism this one could
even communicate to that one what he's
learned or what she's learned and
communicate a good chunk of that maybe
not all of it but maybe a reasonable bit
they can describe exactly how they do
something the times of years
when it's good to do it when it's not
good to do it how to plan for the future
what's the history of this new learning
and so what you have going on here is
because of this strong communication
mechanism
so strong
precise
efficient communication
communication
what you have is
a human group or eventually a human
civilization is a label able to have a
collective memory
is able to have a collective
memory in the case of the chimpanzees
they're every generation every champion
chimpanzee is having to relearn the
things that the other chimpanzees might
have already done in previous
generations they're not able to really
move forward or build on those in
significant ways in humans
as information is learned and
experienced gained a good bit of that is
able to be passed on to other humans and
so this what this might be passed on so
all of this might be passed on or a good
chunk of this could be passed on to the
next generation and i'm not even talking
about written language yet this could
even this could still just be oral
communication which is still a very
strong precise efficient means of
communication written communication
takes it to another level but then this
this this person over here maybe she
comes up with other innovations and at
some point you might say well look if
everyone keeps having innovations and
they keep learning what everyone learned
in previous generations maybe this will
tap out the total amount of memory that
that a human being even has and there's
actually a case that maybe this is one
of the reasons why humans even have
larger memories because there is all of
this collective knowledge to gain from
from one generation to another from one
human being to another but there are
some limits to this and this is the
other element where this collective
aspect of collective memory and
collective learning becomes really
powerful
a human being because of the strong
communication mechanism is not just
limited to the knowledge and the
experience in their memory they are able
to tap into so this human being right
over here does not have this skill set
and that skill set maybe gets passed on
to another human being so let me copy
and paste that
so let's say you copy
let's say you paste that this other
human being that's maybe living at the
same time and when that becomes relevant
when that becomes relevant they could
actually tap into it and maybe they
could learn it from that human being or
maybe it's in a different part of
society and this human being can build
certain tools or build certain things
using this information using that
knowledge right over there and then this
human being doesn't need to know that
information they can just leverage the
output of that information to then build
on top of it so what allows human beings
to do is not only convey information and
build on information from generation to
generation human to human it allows all
of the human brains collectively at any
given point of time to be one collective
memory bank that can be used to develop
or innovate in specific domains and
adapt specific to specific parts of the
ecosystem or to teach each other
so all of a sudden this is really unique
as far as we can tell in the animal
kingdom all of a sudden it's not all
about the brain or the memory of one
individual member of a species
it now becomes about the brain or the
memory of the entire civilization or the
entire group of the species and just as
an example of that there's as far as i
know there's no human being who knows
how to do everything that all human
beings know how to do i could imagine
that there are there is a chimpanzee
that knows how to do everything that any
other chimpanzee knows how to do there
are no humans that can be a fighter
pilot a doctor a gymnast a a a
you know a lawyer understands philosophy
speaks 20 different languages as far as
i know that human being does not exist
and that's okay because they can tap
into the experiences the abilities of
other human beings to build up their
civilization none of us as far as we
know knows how to do everything that we
need to actually build our civilization
but the information is in our collective
memory to actually do it
now the next thing you might say is okay
i started with this premise that we have
a strong precise efficient means of
communication and that other animals
don't but don't other animals actually
have some form of language so for
example don't don't some you know for
example even monkeys when they screech
when they're when there is in when they
are in danger that's a form of
communication maybe a form of language
maybe certain animals birds monkeys
maybe they have a song that they sing
that can convey certain things maybe
it's when they are maybe when they are
looking for a mate isn't that a form of
communication and these are these are a
form of communication and a form of
language but these don't really come in
play in terms of the teaching learning
you don't see one chimpanzee making
screeching sounds or learning sounds
they might do a little bit just to warn
maybe
as a warning but there's no deep nuance
or deep precision that's being able to
convey by these by these one-off sounds
or even one-off gestures and what's
particularly powerful about human
language is that it is a symbolic
language
it is a symbolic language and when i say
it's a symbolic language i'm even saying
it in a broader sense than even just
written symbols i'm talking about even
the sounds themselves as so let's let's
go to a time where we did not even have
writings when we talk about symbolic
languages let's think about a
non-symbolic language so in a
non-symbolic language you might have
some sound let's call it sound one and
it has some meaning let's call it
meaning one
meaning one so this might be a certain
type of scream it means that a predator
is approaching then you might have
something like a sound two or gesture
two and then it has some other meaning
it has meaning too it might be a certain
type of song which means that i am in
the mood to reproduce or whatever else
you might have gesture three
gesture three that has some direct
meaning it might mean that i have found
food or something like that so meaning
three what humans have they can do this
where particular sounds have particular
meanings so for example in humans you
could have sound one
it refers to meaning one i'll just refer
to meaning one you could have sound two
that refers to meaning two
you could have sound three that is
refers to meaning three so these are
just direct representations but what is
really powerful about symbolic languages
is that these these oral symbols can be
combined according to set rules or
grammars to have an infinite number of
meanings so what this is what really
makes human language transcend
other languages and really makes it this
robust precise communication mechanism
is you could have combination sound one
sound two sound three will now have
another meaning meaning four then you
can maybe have a combination where you
have sound three sound one and sound two
might have meaning five and if you have
tens of thousands of sounds when really
our oral words are those sounds in a
given language then all of a sudden you
can have infinite meanings by putting
them in different combinations and if
you think this is a little bit abstract
imagine that sound one is the sound me
saying the word dog and i'm not even
going to write it down because i want to
imagine a world even before written
communication so sound 1 is the sound
dog
sound 2 is a sound eats
and sound three is the sound man
so literally sound one if you heard dog
you think okay i'd visualize a dog of
some type and even there that you know
you well you'd have some visualization
of a dog and we all have one maybe sound
two if you heard eats you'd say okay i
imagine eating in some way and sound
three man you have some visualization of
it and if it was a non-symbolic language
that's all you could get out of those
three sounds but now in a symbolic
language we can combine those we could
say dog eats man so once again we just
reused the three sounds the three
symbols but now they're referring to a
whole new a much more complex meaning
than just referring to certain objects
or certain actions or you could have man
eat dog and it's not pleasant but i
guess in a desperate situation but once
again it is another meaning that that we
can get out of the same sounds and what
these symbolic languages do besides
giving you an infinite number of
meanings they're allowed to give you
more nuance and really refer to things
that are abstract and including and prob
maybe most importantly things like the
present the future the past kind of
hypothetical things that really are
necessary in order to really communicate
or optimally communicate all of the
experiences or the learnings
from one from one entity to another